the first Instagram photo was of your
girlfriend's foot stray dog yeah but it
was maybe the first filter that was even
more consequential had I known that that
was going to be the first photo on
Instagram and that Instagram would get
to this place where as 500 million
people using it around the world monthly
I would have tried a little bit harder
my girlfriend at the time is now my wife
and she said I'm not going to post
photos unless I can make them look great
so you probably should add filters and I
was like okay I'm going to try making a
filter I made X Pro - which was the
first filter that um that we ever
created and I added it to the build and
I took a photo of her foot in a stray
dog I posted it as a test and it just
lived on forever so how quickly did it
become something that you realized could
be not just big but really big I may
have been a little bit optimistic but
the second we launched I was like
there's something new and different here
I had worked at other companies that
struggled to get a hundred people to
sign up in a day and that first morning
are actually the first day we had 25,000
people sign up and I remember like my
eyes were why I was like I've never seen
a service grow that quickly day one the
way we saw we kind of had lightning in a
bottle and it was our job to capture it
and to continue to work on it not screw
it up and this day we think about that
as our job is just keep it going it's
got a life of its own don't get in its
way and make it awesome